[Musique]
le 6 mai 2012 françois hollande devient
le septième président de la cinquième
république française
il vient de gagner le second tour de
l'élection présidentielle avec près de
52% des voix contre le président sortant
nicolas sarkozy mais était-il le
candidat préféré des français
que se serait-il passé si on avait
demandé le soir même au peuple français
on vous laisse une dernière chance est
ce que vous voulez remplacer hollande
par un autre candidat du genre françois
bureau et bien des statistiques
officieuses montre que si un tel
référendum avait été proposé le soir
même alors le peuple aurait choisi de
destituer hollande au profit de perrault
et ça c'est bizarre non
le peuple français vient d'élire un
président qui souhaiterait pourtant
destitué immédiatement au profit d'un
autre candidat
si vous avez suivi cette série vous ne
devriez plus être surpris
le candidat élu par un scrutin a été lu
par ce scrutin
modifier le scrutin et l'élu sera autres
du coup jusque là on étudiait diverses
copains et on en a étudié les propriétés
notamment en termes d'indépendance aux
alternatives non pertinentes et en
termes peu 10 m du vote utile
on a vu des théorèmes antidémocratique
qui montre qu'aucun scrutin ne peut
combiner toutes les bonnes propriétés
quand on a vu qu'on pouvait quand même
construire un scrutin avec d'assez
bonnes propriétés le jugement
majoritaire en notant les candidats mais
pour le mathématicien que je suis tous
ces scrutins ont quelque chose d'assez
arbitraire j'ai l'impression qu'on a
collé des bouts de bois pour faire une
chaise c'est en maths c'est moche c'est
horriblement moche
du coup pour aujourd'hui je vous propose
une toute autre approche on va
construire un scrutin naturel on va
construire un scrutin élégant et ce
n'est qu'ensuite qu'on découvrira tout
émerveillé que ce scrutin parce qu'il
est élégant possède de très belles
propriétés
mais pour commencer il nous faut un
principe fondateur un principe il est
prenable
un principe élégant dans mes années de
recherche en théorie des systèmes de
vote je n'ai croisé qu'un seul tel
principe est l'auteur de ce principe est
devenue l'une de mes plus grandes idoles
génie auquel je pense c'est le
philosophe et mathématicien mari jean
antoine nicolas de carita marquis de
condorcet où il devait galéré à écrire
son nom dans la marge à l'école
condorcet est l'un de mes grands héros
il fait partie d'une short list de
personnalités à qui j ai parlé si
j'avais une machine à remonter dans le
temps à côté peut-être d'archimède
einstein et la place condorcet était un
précurseur de nombreux concepts en
théorie de la démocratie en probabilité
deux de mes domaines préféré des
mathématiques
il est aussi l'un des premiers à avoir
philosophie sur le problème des
incitatifs si chère à la théorie des
jeux et sur l' avantage d'avoir de
nombreux avis peu fiable plutôt qu'un
avis assez fiable un principe que l'on
applique aujourd'hui en justice via la
prise de décisions par jour est plutôt
que par un juge et que les chercheurs en
intelligence artificielle re découvre
régulièrement à leur grand étonnement
condorcet était aussi l'auteur de
nombreuses idées progressistes qui
mettront des siècles être accepté comme
les droits des femmes et des minorités
ou l'abolition de la peine de mort à
l'asse suite à ces protestations contre
l'utilisation abusive de la guillotine
pendant la terreur qui fut arrêté et
emprisonné condensé mourut empoisonné
deux jours plus tard dans des
circonstances encore mystérieuses
le mouvement démocratique qui leur a
initié aura eu raison de lui
dans le cadre de la théorie des systèmes
de vote condorcet et non ça le principe
fondamental qui suit si un candidat est
préféré par la majorité à n'importe quel
autre candidat
alors il doit être élu dans le cas de
l'élection de 2012 on a vu que le
président hollande n'était pas un coeur
de condorcet puisqu'une majorité préféré
berrou à hollande
en fait berrou était vainqueur de
condorcet en effet en duel il battait
tout autre candidat autrement dit le 6
mai 2012 si françois bo avait été élu
président de la république alors aucun
référendum n'aurait pu remettre en cause
son élection et c'est pour ça que je
trouve le principe de condorcet
absolument brillant et remarquablement
naturel
si le but d'une élection et de suivre
l'avis de la majorité alors il n'y a pas
de doute à avoir
il faut élire le vainqueur de condorcet
on peut aisément lire le vainqueur de
condorcet sur un graphe le plus grave
des duels se gravent contient les
candidats avec une flèche de dominance
d'un candidat à vers le candidat rhdp si
une majorité préfère à ab ainsi dans
notre cas il ya une flèche de beyrouth à
hollande
carbeo domine hollande en duel pourquoi
béraud est-il vainqueur de condorcet
cela devrait vous sauter aux yeux sur ce
dessin toutes les flèches parts de
perrault berube a donc tous les autres
candidats en duel comprendre et
interpréter les résultats d'une élection
à la con morsay ne devrait pas poser de
problème sauf que me demanderiez vous
comment doit-on voté pour obtenir ce
graphe des duels
est ce que pour cheikh duels on doit
annoncer notre préférence donc forte
heureusement peut faire beaucoup plus
simple pour voter dans un scrutin à la
condenser il suffit de classer les
on ida par ordre de préférence alors
s'il ya beaucoup de candidats ça peut
devenir long fastidieux et compliqué de
classer tous les candidats rassurez-vous
le scrutin de converser n'exige pas des
classements complets dans votre vote si
vous le voulez vous pouvez très bien
dire que vous êtes un différend entre le
parti anticapitaliste et la lutte
ouvrière
mieux encore s'il ya un candidat dont
vous n'avez jamais entendu parler si
vous ne savez pas comment le classer
vis-à-vis des autres vous pouvez très
bien choisir de ne le comparez à
personne et ça ça pourrait être
particulièrement pertinent lorsque la
liste des candidats est monstrueuse
comme quand il faut recruter des jeunes
joueurs de football prometteur
déterminer les articles à accepter dans
une conférence scientifique ou élire la
meilleure vidéo scientifique de l'année
le problème c'est que chaque membre du
jury n'a sans doute pas vu toutes les
vidéos scientifique de l'année
en fait chaque membre du jury dans a
sans doute vu qu'une infime portion
peut-on encore appliqué un scrutin dans
ce cadre via un scrutin la condorcet la
réponse est oui
chaque électeur se contentera alors de
classer les 30 meilleures vidéos qu'il a
vu et on pourra alors reconstituer un
graphe des duels entre vidéo
scientifique ce cadre pose certes
d'autres problèmes comme la potentielle
non unicité du vainqueur de condorcet où
la faible connectivité du graff des
duels mais ces problèmes n'ont rien
d'insurmontable et pourrait même
permettre de mieux comprendre les liens
entre vidéo scientifique mais je m'égare
revenons aux copains de condorcet chaque
avec leur vote
un classement des candidats à partir des
bulletins de vote ou construit le graver
des duels et on élit ensuite le
vainqueur de condorcet qui est celui
duquel toutes les flèches parts et le
tour est joué
non en fait quand vous y réfléchissez
tout ceci était bien connue du marquis
de condorcet il y a plus de deux siècles
pourtant on n'a pas adopté le scrutin de
condorcet mais pourquoi donc est ce que
c'est parce qu'il est trop compliqué non
le problème du scrutin de condorcet ce
qui a bloqué la recherche sur les
scrutins à la conte dansé pendant plus
de deux siècles
c'est ce que condorcet a appelé le
paradoxe de condorcet imaginons que
trois électeurs ont vu les vidéos de
sciences étonnante d'albert le chat et
demi que matt sur les systèmes de
le premier électeurs préfèrent science
étonnante à albert a big mat
le second préfère albert amic natation
c'est au nantes et le troisième milk
maths à 107,90 à albert alors sans sitôt
nantes bat albert en duel grâce au
support des électeurs 1 et 3 albert bas
mic mac grâce à ceux de 1 et 2 unique
matt bassens étonnante grâce à deux et
trois
mais alors on ainsi que dans le graphe
des duels et aucune vidéo ne bat les
deux autres il n'y a pas de vainqueur de
condorcet que faire dans ce cas
condorcet jeu tu as ébranlèrent et de
siècle de mathématiciens limitèrent on
semblait face à un mur infranchissable
et puis en février 2010 est un jeune
mathématicien publié un article avec une
solution pour franchir le mur
infranchissable
bon en fait le jeune mathématicien en
question il n'est pas le premier y
arriver et tout ce qu'il a fait en gros
c'est voler des idées à gauche à droite
et les reformuler juste comme il faut
pour que condorcet soit fier de lui le
gros du travail avait en fait déjà été
faits notamment par rémy père dans une
excellente série d'articles sur le site
images du match mais aussi par de
nombreux autres chercheurs comme brian
fisher la font l'acier
le breton créé uras fishburne mayer seul
aziz brendle bran de scie dick et bien
d'autres quoi qu'il en soit on connaît
aujourd'hui une façon de franchir le mur
infranchissable
mais pour ce faire va falloir utiliser
un cheat code qui va peut-être pas
plaire à tout le monde
il va nous falloir utiliser un scrutin
non déterministe à l'instar de la
l'autocratie dont on a parlé dans
l'épisode 3 ça veut dire que le dimanche
soir une fois que tous les bulletins
seront collectées que le crash des duels
sera construit ce qui sera élu ne sera
pas un candidat mais une loi de
probabilité
une loterie sur les candidats et ce
n'est que le lundi matin une fois que
l'on est sûr que tous les bulletins de
vote on était bien comptabilisé que l'on
tirera le candidat élu conformément aux
probabilités assigné aux différents
candidats par la loterie et lui le
dimanche soir il reste à répondre à la
question suivante quelle loterie élire
le dimanche soir et bien l'idée de
suivre à la lettre les prescriptions des
condorcet
l'argument crucial de condorcet était
cette idée de préférence de la majorité
entre différentes alternatives pour
étendre ses idéaux de loterie il nous
faut donc une manière de définir les
préférences de la majorité entre
différentes loteries et la définition la
plus naturelle pour ce faire est sans
doute la suivante on va dire que nos
tripes et est préférée à une loterie pu
par la majorité
si lorsque je tire un candidat x selon
la loterie paix et un candidat y
seulement 1 loterie qu alors la majorité
préfère x et y plus souvent qu'elle ne
préfère y ax on peut maintenant dessiner
un grave de duel des loteries dont les
noms sont des loteries et avec une
flèche de la loterie paix à la loterie
q6 en duel
la majorité préfère la loterie paix à la
loterie
q jusque là on a vraiment pris à la
lettre les concepts de condenser et on
les a généralisé de la manière la plus
naturelle qui soit aux loteries
on a ainsi obtenu un graphe de duel des
loteries et a priori ce graphique est
infinie est très difficile à étudier
pourtant il possède une propriété
fondamentale qui est très certainement
mon théorème préféré de toutes les
mathématiques le tram en question est le
suivant à moins qu'il n'y ait une
égalité entre deux candidats
il existe toujours un unique vainqueur
de condorcet des loteries à j'aimerais
tellement pouvoir raconter cette trame à
condorcet je suis sûr qu'elle rendrait
heureux ce théorème été absolument
remarquable il s'agit quasiment d'un
commandement sachant qu'il ya quasiment
toujours un unique vainqueur de pau
d'orsay des lots trio pas le choix si on
croit au principe de condorcet il nous
faut absolument élire la loterie
vainqueur de condorcet et bien c'est ça
le scrutin de condorcet randomisés sur
lesquels j'ai travaillé c'est le scrutin
qui élit la loterie vainqueur de
condorcet et ça c'est joli c'est naturel
c'est électorat en fait c'est tellement
élégant et naturel que je suis
aujourd'hui persuadé que s'il ya des
aliens très intelligent à l'autre bout
de la galaxie mais vraiment été j'en ai
pas connu alors c'est forcément ce
scrutin de condorcet randomisés qu'ils
utilisent
et oui parce qu'en plus d'être élégant
et naturels ou peut-être parce qu'il est
élégant et naturel
le scrutin de condorcet randomisée à de
très bonnes propriétés pour commencer
s'il existe un vainqueur de condorcet
déterministe alors par unis cité du
vainqueur de condorcet le scrutin de
condorcet randomisés va élire forcément
le vainqueur de condorcet déterministe
or en pratique en politique des études
empiriques et théoriques montre que en
général il y ait un vainqueur de
condorcet déterministe du coup le
scrutin de condorcet randomisés en
pratique va souvent nous donner une
réponse déterministe alors vous pouvez
peut-être vouloir mettre un bémol pour
le cas où le vainqueur de condorcet des
loteries n'est pas déterministe il
serait alors élu par une loterie
mais alors je vous rappelle qu'il n'ya
alors aucun principe fondamental qui
justifierait l'élection déterministe
d'un candidat comme les maîtres d'albert
très bien expliqué dans cette vidéo
et comme je vous l'expliquais dans le
premier épisode de cette série les
vainqueurs d'un scrutin sont déterminés
par ce scrutin
modifier le scrutin et le vainqueur sera
autres du coup plutôt que suivre l'avis
arbitraire d'un scrutin déterministe
décidée par le hasard n'est pas si mal
et d'ailleurs même dans le cas où le
vainqueur de condorcet n'est pas
déterministe les candidats qui ont une
probabilité non nulle d'être élus ne
seront pas des candidats lanka si un
candidat a réussi à avoir une
probabilité non nul des tris lui c'est
qu'il a un soutien d'une majorité
remarquable dans le sens où il bat en
duel d'autres candidats que la majorité
soutient de façon remarquable en
particulier contrairement à la
l'autocratie le scrutin de condorcet n'a
aucune chance d'élire une alternative
extrême ou par alternative extrême
j'entends une alternative dont 80% de la
population se dit vivement contre par
exemple si dans le vote de la meilleure
vidéo de l'année je rajoutais ma vidéo
sur le scrutin à la de borda et si une
très grande majorité des électeurs la
détester en particulier si elle perdait
un duel contre n'importe quel autre
vidéo
alors ma vidéo sur de borda malgré 20 %
d'aficionado aurait une probabilité nul
d'être élue la loterie vainqueur de
condorcet dans ce cas consisterait à
choisir uniformément aléatoirement entre
les trois autres vidéos
bref à mon sens l'argument principal
pour l'utilisation du scrutin de
condenser randomisés c'est la légitimité
de la loterie élus après tout la loterie
élu par le scrutin de condorcet
randomisés n'est autre que le vainqueur
de condorcet des loteries
mais il ya d'autres raisons moins
philosophique d'adopter le scrutin de
condenser contrairement aux scrutins
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui le scrutin de
condorcet randomisés est indépendant aux
alternatives dont pertinente
ce qui veut dire qu'un candidat n'aura
jamais de remords à s'être présentés et
avoir défendu ses idées mais surtout
contrairement à quasiment tous les
scrutins dont on a parlé jusque là à
l'exception de la dictature aléatoire
quand il existe un vainqueur de
condorcet le scrutin de condorcet
randomisés ferme la porte au dilemme du
vote utile
un électeur a intérêt à voter selon ses
vrais préférence et ça plus le fait que
le scrutin de condorcet randomisée et
lille et vainqueur de condorcet
déterministe lorsqu'il existe ça veut
dire qu'un vainqueur de condorcet
déterministe sera toujours élu et le
sera de façon parfaitement légitime
puisqu'il sera avec les vrais préférence
des électeurs
on peut même démontré que les scrutins
qui satisfont cette propriété sont très
rares
le scrutin de condorcet randomisés est à
peu près le seul à avoir cette jolie
propriété pour les détaille t il vos
envois vers mon article lu scrutin de
condorcet randomisés a aussi
d'excellentes propriétés en terme de
groupe stratégie poupounes et là encore
je vous renvoie vers l'article pour en
savoir plus bref vous l'aurez compris
j'ai un scrutin préféré mon scrutin
préféré est le scrutin de condorcet
randomisée et si je devais choisir
dictatorialement notre système
démocratique je n'hésiterai pas une
seconde c'est le scrutin de condorcet
randomisés que je reposerai les neuf en
a parlé du jugement majoritaire le
scrutin inventé par michel balinski et
rida laraki est devenu corrida l'arrêt
qui a commenté l'épisode précédent ce
que je trouve super cool ça m'a fait
super plaisir en tout cas il a rejoué
quelques précisions notamment le fait
que le scrutin par note n'a pas été bon
les parcs de bordeaux fête le scrutin la
de borda consistait à classer les
candidats et à donner une note à chacun
dia qui dépendaient du classement c'est
ce qu'on avait vu très rapidement dans
l'épisode 1 on a parlé un moment du
scrutin la demande à son ancien devant
là mais j'ai pas envie d'insister
davantage sur le scrutin l'abordable
parce que ce que ce mandat il n'a pas
beaucoup de bonnes propriétés notamment
il est pas indépendant interactive non
pertinentes et lille ouvre grandement la
porte au dilemme du vote utile
j'ai oublié de vous recommander à
norfolk aux commandes aujourd'hui le
livre de rida laraki sur le jugement
majoritaire
il ya notamment toute un récapitulatif
historique sur piste à 9h général et
système de vote par notation en
particulier j'ai aussi eu le plaisir
inventaire de élections alternatives
qu'ils proposent sur son site web de
voter souvent le jugement majoritaire
pour le futur président de la république
on ne sait pas le vote officiel
c'est ça qui m'a dit le président de
river mais ça vous permet de sentir ce
que donne le jugement majoritaire
nicolas mas bière et koné chlorés que se
pose la question de l'applicabilité du
jugement majoritaire en pratique puisque
a fortiori ça rendrait le décompte des
votes beaucoup plus complexe et
notamment calculé la médiane parmi cinq
valeurs c'est facile mais calcule la
médiane quand on a des milliers
de données ça devient tout de suite
impossible à faire à la main il faut un
ordinateur pour pouvoir faire cela
et du coup on sera obligé de passer au
vote électronique alors le vote
électronique c'est un sujet passionnant
notamment d'un point de vue mathématique
il faudrait tout un épisode voir
plusieurs épisodes pour bien en parler
or pour l'instant je suis pas du tout
suffisamment bien à l'aise avec toute la
théorie des jouets électroniques pour
pouvoir vous en parler comme ça ça
viendra peut-être plus tard dans cette
série mais je vous garantis rien ce que
je peux dire maintenant et rapidement
sur le vote électronique c'est que
aujourd'hui il faut absolument ne pas
utiliser le vote électronique vendu par
des entreprises faut absolument que le
vote électronique soit quelque chose d'
open source de public et qui utilise des
cryptographie public pour bien connu
pour pouvoir sécuriser l'anonymat du
vote c'est quelque chose de très
difficile à faire vous pouvez l'imaginer
mais aujourd'hui il y à des algorithmes
à qui ont été proposées même des trucs
disponible en ligne
hélios qui propose de faire des scrutins
en ligne de façon parfaitement
anonymisées et sécurisé alors ça
garantit pas encore tout à fait
l'anonymat et confidentialité que
garantit l'isoloir
mais j'ai envie de dire qu'il faut peser
les pour et les contres des isoloirs
notamment aux états unis les élections
ont lieu un mardi un jour de travail
donc aller voter c'est ça peut être très
compliqué et en france le second tour de
l'élection présidentielle aura lieu le
week-end du 8 mai comme qui là encore ça
peut être compliqué d'aller voter
si on a prévu un week-end de trois jours
bref tout ça pour dire que le vote
électronique surtout au vu des avancées
très très récente en matière de
cryptographie et des résultats des
théorèmes qui montre que certaines
manipulations du vote électronique ne
sont impossibles il me semble qu'il va
falloir petit à petit considérer le vote
électronique comme une alternative de
plus en plus crédible encore une fois il
ne faut pas utiliser les votes
électroniques proposés par les
entreprises privées aujourd'hui qu'ils
soient notamment si c'est pas du open
source il faut pas le faire
mais petit à petit il ya des nouvelles
technologies qui sortent et encore une
fois c'est des trucs très récent et je
pense que je finirais par faire un
épisode dessus autre inquiétude soulevée
par le colonel cloniques à savoir le
fait que ces scrutins que l'on propose
jugement est majoritaire ou condorcet
randomisés sont des scrutins beaucoup
plus sophistiqué que les systèmes à un
tour et à deux tours que les électeurs
quand il se souvient en effet sabres
après il faut que le peuple part que les
électeurs soient capables de comprendre
le scrutin pour pouvoir pour qu'il se
puisse être appliquée alors je pense que
le jugement majoritaire est vraiment pas
si compliqué n'importe qui peut le
comprendre
le scrutin de condorcet de base peut
être très bien compris par n'importe qui
on mars et randomisée j'avoue ça
commençait à être compliqué c'est pour
ça que je sais pas s'il va être vraiment
applicable en pratique
ceci étant dit je pense que les gens
sont surtout à l'aise avec ce avec
lequel ils ont l'habitude d'interagir
donc la première étape si on veut que
ces scrutins soient appliquées dans cinq
ans je pense qu'ils sont pas appliquées
pas aux prochaines élections
mais pour qu'il soit appliqué dans cinq
ans la première étape c'est de les
mettre dans notre quotidien
alors ça fait plusieurs années que je me
dis qu'il faut que j'écrive une
application pour téléphone où on utilise
ces scrutins pour qu on se familiarise
avec ces scrutins
une fois qu'on sera familiarisé avec ces
scrutins qui sont pas si compliqué une
fois qu'on est famille rezaï qu'on voit
les conséquences des votes que l'on peut
faire je pense que ça deviendra une
évidence qu'il faut les utiliser
donc tout ça ça me donne l'occasion de
réitérer ma suggestion nombreux viewers
que j'ai maintenant serait cool qui est
une app qui proposent ces scrutins
non pas pour voter pour le prochain
président de la république mais pour
décider quel sera le film à voir ce soir
ou entre amis dans quel restaurant aller
ou que sais-je encore le lieu où la date
union toutes ces décisions collectives
peut être élus par scrutin
et c'est souvent beaucoup plus efficace
beaucoup moins chronophage de faire ça
parce qu'autant c'est décidé c'est
évident à quelqu'un de prendre la
responsabilité si ça se passe mal ça a
été décidé parce que tant que je pense
que c'est une très bonne solution pour
prendre des décisions collectives en
pratique et si c'est une nappe qui le
fait c'est très facile à mettre en place
les gens vont l'utiliser et font
s'habituerait cela et par l'utilisation
les gens vont se rendre compte que c'est
beaucoup beaucoup mieux que les scrutins
à un tour il ya deux tours comme
utilisent aujourd'hui
donc voilà si vous voulez changer les
élections présidentielles pour dans cinq
ans je pense que la chose la plus
efficace est versée d'écrire une ap de
la proposer deux ans voir et je serai le
premier à promouvoir une app qui une
bonne ap qui propose tout ça surtout si
en plus elle est open source et elle en
code tous les systèmes cryptographiques
du vote électronique pesait notamment
par helios mathieu rousseau fait la
remarque que le cas de vote utile que
j'ai présenté dans la vidéo précédente
était assez peu oppressante ifs en fait
pour qu'ils aient l'opportunité d'avoir
un vote utile qui change
l'issue du vote il faut que la médiane
puisse être manipulé par au moins une
personne qui a un intérêt à manipuler
cette médiane et c'est pas évident dans
ce qu on a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'électeurs et finalement peu de notes
possibles priori beaucoup de gens qui
ont joué la médiane et à ce moment là
personne pourra bouger la médiane est en
effet en pratique il ya peu de chances
que quiconque et le pouvoir de en
changeant son vote changé l'issue
d'élections mais ça cette remarque
s'applique aussi au scrutin à un tour et
à de toi le problème du vote utile c'est
pas que une personne sache qu'elle n'y
changera à l'issue du vote
en changeant son vote le problème du
vote utile c'est que si beaucoup de
personnes changent leur vote se
coordonnent d'une certaine manière pour
modifier l'issue de l'élection alors ils
pourront modifier l'issue de l'élection
et a privé ça peut paraître débile de
penser que plusieurs personnes vont
pouvoir changer leur vote comme ça du
jour au lendemain pour changer l'issue
de l'élection
en fait il ya des gens qui sont capables
d'influencer beaucoup de personnes dans
leur direction de bottes dont leur
pression de beauté notamment les hommes
politiques les médias et tout ça
et par exemple en australie où j'utilise
volts alternatif où il y à des
stratégies de vote qui peuvent être
compliqué à mettre en place les
politiciens mettent des tracteurs
circulation qui incite les électeurs à
voter utilise par exemple typiquement à
m le candidat rival au candidat favori
en dernière position dans un vote
alternatif ou dans le cas du jugement
majoritaire ça serait lui donner une
très mauvaise note et ce phénomène est
d'autant plus accentuée par le fait que
les sondages aujourd'hui jouent un rôle
très important dans les stratégies des
votes des électeurs
du coup grâce aux sondages on sait entre
qui et qui se jouer et puis si on fait
un jugement majorité on saura quels sont
les notes médiane du coup si on a un
candidat favori et qu'on a un rival à
cette combine son candidat et qu'on a
attribué une note au dessus de la note
médiane à sept autres candidats
alors il y aura un design du vote utile
on pourra vouloir mettre une note à
candidat rival qui est en dessous de sa
note médiane d'après les sondages bref
diène du vote utile ça reste un problème
pour le jugement majoritaire et samuel
bouder souligne une autre défaillance du
jugement majoritaire savoir que le
jugement majoritaire est satisfait
l'unanimité mais il ne satisfait pas la
quasi unanimité
je m'explique imaginons que l'on fasse
un scrutin où on vit le meilleur commis
entre pommes poires et des bananes
disons que on a des électeurs qui
préfère largement la pomme à la poire et
à la banane du coup ils vont peut-être
mettre 20 sur 20 à la pomme ont sur 20 à
la poire et zéro sur vingt à la banane
ensuite on a d'autres secteurs qui adore
la banane puis la pomme et la poire 100
électeurs de ce joueur nizon du coup ils
vont mettre 20 sur 20 à la banane ils
vont mettre 9 sur 20 à la pomme est zéro
sur vingt à la poire et enfin on a un
électeur un électeur au milieu de ces
deux cents autres éric soeur qui lui est
très mitigé entre les trois points
et préfère très légèrement la boire du
coup il va mettre on sur 20 à la fois 10
sur 20 à la pomme et 9 sur 20 à la
banane et bien vous pouvez remarquer que
quels que soient le fruit les lecteurs
le dernier acteur que j'ai mentionné est
en fait l'électeur médian c'est lui qui
détermine en fait les notes médiane des
différents fruits et du coup ce sera la
poire qui remportera d'élections
maintenant retirons la banane l'on voit
très bien que dans cette élection en
fait la pomme est préféré à la poire par
quasiment tout le monde sauf notre
dernier électeur donc ici on faisait un
référendum pomme contrepoids et ben
n'aurait 200 contre 1 pour la pomme sauf
que c'est pas la pomme qui a été élu
donc le jugement majoritaire ne
satisfait pas le rater la quasi
unanimité du vote
c'est hier que si quasiment tout le
monde préfère la pomme à la poire c'est
pas dit que la pomme gagne l'élection en
jugement majoritaire
je vous conseille notamment cet article
qui liste d'autres paradoxe lié au
jugement majoritaire pour voir ses
limites
encore une fois le jugement majoritaire
est pas parfait mon sens je pense qu'il
est parfait au sens de personnes dont
qui méritent pas 20 sur 20 au classement
des scrutins mais il est nettement mieux
que les scrutins à un tour et aldo
du coup je ne m'oppose absolument pas
son application en pratique même si mon
ce que tu as préféré c'est pas le
jugement majoritaire
c'est le scrutin de condorcet randomisés
espère que vous avez mais cet épisode il
y aura un épisode hardcore jeudi où on
va rentrer un peu plus dans les détails
mathématiques de ce scrutin de condorcet
randomisés notamment sur certains
théorème de mon article
cet épisode clos si la partie sur les
scrutins à utiliser de nos systèmes
démocratiques et à partir du prochain
épisode on verra d'autres applications
de la théorie des jeux à l'analyse de
nos sociétés
de la manière dont on vit ensemble en
particulier dans le prochain épisode
on verra une cause majeure de la bi
polarisation idéologique croissante dans
nos sociétés si vous avez aimé cet
épisode conseil le lichen le commentaire
à le partager pensez à vous abonner pour
ne pas manquer les épisodes merci aussi
peur pour leurs dons et j'espère que
souterrain la prochaine fois si le
candidat 1 est confronté aux candidats 2
c'est le président a un qui gagnent
si le candidat de est confronté aux
candidats 3 c'est le candidat 2 qui
gagne et si le candidat 3 est confronté
aux candidats un c'est le candidat 3 qui
gagne à l'élection présidentielle de
2007 il y avait douze candidats et les
sondages de l'époque prédisait que
françois bayrou aurait battu en duel
n'importe lequel des onze autres
candidats